[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello welcome back to the break room uh
the nerdy news show that talks about all
the the late breaking fun nerdy things
that you want to be talking about live
from new rockstars offices here in los
angeles my name is zach colston i'm
thrilled to be joined by we got coy
jandro down there we got uh jessica
clements right there and we got tom
michelson right here um today
these four folks are going to be
discussing we got some harley quinn news
we got like
some interesting stuff about reed
richards in multiverse of madness a lot
of
very fun very visual d23 news um we're
gonna get into all of that today also
quick happy birthday to producer dodson
who um is in the chat running polls and
things like that today's his birthday
everybody say happy birthday dadson in
the chat
here
we go
we got a birthday dotson right here
he's sitting in the dark uh questioning
his birthday life choices
for today we appreciate everybody that's
in the chat already uh speculating on
who's gonna be on the show whose arm was
partially visible we appreciate all of
you um
for today we're doing a super chat
redemption we're going to hulk out in
honor of she-hulk episode three coming
out tonight uh jessica's going to be
doing the breakdown on the channel very
excited to see that as excited i'm as
excited for your breakdown as i am for
the actual show yeah
it's true
oh i thought there was four out and i
was like you like the first two
after the year
i desired that's a good thing
i'm just prepared
i was like a genuine compliment would it
be in front of them
that
we're on a birthday kind of edge today
guys uh we could snap maybe we could
hulk out okay yes for every hundred
dollars we raised in super chats we one
of us will be hulking out on a topic of
our choosing uh it will be screamy it
will be veiny in the face you know i
mean it'll be a good a good solid hulk
out you'll have to you have to drop us
some coin to find out what exactly
that'll look like uh but first we've got
some really fun headlines to discuss
headlines
yes
whoa the mj2997 um
already throwing in 50 doubloons there
thank you mj uh
hulk it out yo we will um first hp max
renewed harley quinn for season four
right ahead of the season three finale
that's coming up september 15th um this
i mean there shouldn't be surprising
news because that show is beloved and
seems to be a huge success but with
warner brothers and hbo max every
renewal is a bit of a surprise right now
right especially animation has kind of
been getting i was nervous because it
isn't that uh the harlequin show is not
in the same as everybody else's show
like how like uh then when they gave up
the diagram of what could be canceled
harley quinn was one of those shows that
could have been canceled but it got
renewed yeah it's all good so for fans
of of harlot that harley quinn show
great news we've got another season
actually they are promoting
um sarah peters who is a writer on
workaholics master of none and nathan
for you uh and has written on the series
is getting promoted to um show runner
for the next season which is great news
uh we're excited for that show uh
speaking of dc
um so if you can hear like um
uh there is we are installing uh an
underground pool outside the road
yeah
yeah we'll be doing a hot tub meta on
this show uh pretty soon as soon as you
get a vibration i'm usually more
professional but it's so distracting i
think i'm on
speaking of dc so this is this is not
the first name but um these rumors keep
coming up of who's gonna be dc's
quote-unquote kevin feige right they're
looking for somebody to be in charge of
the dceu to be the shepherd kind of like
zack snyder was for a while for dc and
certainly like kevin feige has been for
a long time for marvel uh a new name
that is getting floated emma watts not
to be confused with emma watson
okay very different person uh who is a
producer she worked at um paramount
where she produced the last time she's
also worked for james cameron i think
produced elita battle angel and worked
on avatar um her name is getting floated
she hasn't officially been hired we
don't know but her name is getting
floated through the trade papers
interesting
i don't know what that means
wait what the like her becoming the
kevin feige yeah we don't know what
happened
i mean it would be cool and and
certainly they need to make somebody
that but like we don't necessarily know
what her version of the dc is she the
same producer as um
christopher nolan's partner uh emma is
it emma watts or um maybe if you know
the chat you can let us know but yeah
his um long-time producer and i think
partners emma
no i think that is a different app
that's a different i don't think
i think the biggest takeaway from this
is that there's a kevin feige coming
into the dc yes and they have actually
talked about it is like this is a rumor
it's like okay this person's gonna be as
big as kevin feige are they gonna pull
us in the right direction with dc yeah
so i think that's the big takeaway i
think it's also really smart to get
ahead of it to be like hey we we hear
your complaints we want you to know
we're putting everything in this like we
have a focal point we've got a new goal
this feels like the 10-year plan they've
been saying for 15 years like if they
they land a person to guide us on a
journey because we've heard the plan
before but then it went from like zack
snyder to matt reeves having a cornered
all these just disparate things i think
this matt reeves announcement is very
smart to keep over here and let him run
his universe and then be very vocal when
you hire someone new and then have them
be the fandom face have them do what
feige does being a front-facing
executive and that means they need to be
you know smart with world building very
hands-on but also be able to do that
delivering a messages like you know
steve jobs-esque where they're the face
of a thing yeah and i think that's smart
of dc to model themselves in that
specific way after marvel but hopefully
not so specific that they pull into the
same pitfalls of marvel where if people
don't get exactly what they want it
feels like a lesser experience like we
don't want it to chase the dragon of
marvel because it should be its own i
don't see a world in which dc fans could
be completely disappointed by the
product that gets put out right i don't
think it's fun loving free spirits
they're gonna be so chill about whatever
happens in the next 10 years probably
yeah and clearly
i mean a cool job who wouldn't want to
be in charge of like a huge cinematic
university but also
incredibly hard high pressure i mean
you know google kathleen kennedy and
like what you know her experience at
lucasfilm if you want to know like how
tough a gig uh running a big enterprise
like that can be but uh we'll see the
news in development um oh okay this is a
fun story so
it's always great when like something
leaks out of like uh you know the
spanish language uh outpost of marvel or
something like that so in a now deleted
article in disney latin america uh they
posted this this article that listed the
five most important superheroes for mcu
phase five okay that seems like
oh not a big deal um the fact that it's
deleted is fascinating and then the list
is very interesting okay an honorable
mention to captain america sam wilson
nice to them he's got a movie coming up
right in fact five makes sense um but
then like they put them as an honorable
mention yeah not the only part of that
yeah
[Applause]
we couldn't make the top
daredevil
and iron heart gregory williams is it
because they each are they get their own
prop like in the phase five yeah
generally so we don't have a specific uh
place where k bishop is gonna be seen
next unless it's an echo but if you look
at all of these names right like kate
bishop after the hawkeye show very
quickly fan favorite and a lot of people
were like oh she's going to be very
important like we heard those rumors
then after hawkeye of how formative
she's going to be my lopez getting her
own show before we even met her is
clearly someone they're shaping long
term miss marvel had the last beat of
importance like that that is huge uh
charlie cox has said over and over again
that if he plays his cards right he's
good for the next 10 years the fans have
never had a rally quite like the save
daredevil campaign that just makes sense
and then the only one we haven't met is
iron heart but if you look at the way
they structured the first three phases
iron man being integral i imagine
they're gonna want something of that ilk
for the familiarity like if you look at
the way we model ourselves in film there
is a certain like captain america iron
man there's there's a
legacy to sequels and growing franchises
so the under-dimensional cap is funny
but iron heart makes sense so like these
all track but that makes me more
suspicious of the list because it's
almost like who have we heard about most
that and they're still they're still
missing people they're still like i mean
yeah there's a ton of big names we're
also missing kang any anything that's
about sure well and it makes me wonder
like is this list also yeah iron heart
who we haven't seen yet but we know
she's in wakanda forever right uh she's
in the trailer for that um is this kind
of the list instead of like the most
important superheroes for face five more
like hey make sure you know who these
people are well what the hell
is comments familiarize yourself with
these people they're gonna be important
yeah i was noticing that this list kind
of takes care of like the full spectrum
of of the mcu we got street level heroes
like kate bishop and echo my lopez miss
marvel especially now that she's going
into space and the one could argue that
it's a little too street level well but
the thing is that daredevil isn't it
going to be like 20 plus that's yeah
it's like
60 episodes
that's got to be a huge chunk of story
and
even if it's just street level they're
going to be setting up a ton of stuff
that probably bleeds into everything
else just by content alone they left off
like i guess i guess
phase five doesn't have black panther
but it's like whoever is gonna be the
hero of black panther will probably
bleed into whatever the mcu's phase five
is and they left that off the list
there's a i know the blades are there
i think they're being safe and they're
playing it safe and yeah of course haley
steinfeld's going to be on that list
she's done that
no problem with that list it's just
fascinating and there was always a
speculation with something like this was
this just an intern
who got a little keyboard happy you know
what's seo today yes that sounds nice
accidentally hit publish without getting
the approval from uh corporate whatever
but it's fun fun to speculate and we
were working there's gonna be a lot of
speculation later in this episode around
disney plus day d23 next week we've got
a really cool d23 poster that we're
going to be breaking down live and in
person uh
and kind of speculating about what that
could mean for what we're going to see
next week as far as trailers and
announcements but speaking of disney
plus they've revealed the ratings for
loki season two and what if season two
they're both gonna be tv 14.
same ratings they had for season one
okay
that was gonna be my fault those were
like wait what was the first one right
now so they're neither are they're
either more nor less adult
we were saying this is interesting uh
whether the rating is reflective of
anything
uh but that must mean to be able to rate
the shows that means they're pretty
completed that's a good point right like
uh they the the sensors or whatever have
to be able to see a finished product um
and so does that mean we might get
trailers for both these series next week
timing is suspect that's a really
interesting point and they we don't have
release dates official for either so in
the big rollout following comic con
you're going to want like spicy and this
would be like an important thing and we
got we got loki season 2 set photos
several months ago so we know that's
been in production we don't have an
exact release date and then who knows
with the animation
it could have been finished years ago
and they've been sitting on it we have
no idea when that'll stick to the script
and so that's why they'll be able to
they also said that what if was largely
based around phase four right and a
phase four is ending you're gonna want
to get that early in phase five so i
imagine when we look at that phase five
map that i keep i swear it's gonna
expand twice the size yeah we're gonna
see a lot of like but wait there's more
and then
i imagine that's gonna want to be early
in phase four with the way they're
moving out of phase four so quickly
sorry early in phase five i mean like
they'll be yeah so i can see loki and
this especially with kang we don't know
how important kang's gonna be for loki
season two so i i see those needing to
get out yeah both these could be
dropping early next year maybe this is
what our 2023. can we see a 2023 where
every week has a marvel disney plush
show oh god coming out can we can we
picture that in our mind's eye i i mean
i'll cry
i'll break down and that's not to
mention star wars that's not to mention
films um come on we're living in the
best time to be alive uh other than it
being 1000 degrees outside it's the best
time to be alive best time in fiction
that's right
um in an interview with empire uh
multiverse amanda screenwriter michael
wildron a favorite of this channel in
this panel uh revealed he'd originally
written a reed richard's post-credits
scene for multiverse of madness he he
said that he's one of his favorite
characters to write for uh before it was
decided that reed richards was going to
be in the illuminati and get uh turned
into a plato fun factory uh reject there
by um uh yeah by wanda uh it was gonna
be a push credit scene where like
somebody's been recording the events of
the movie in a stretchy hand like
reaches out to hit record or play or
whatever like that probably from the
baxter building that was of course
rejected they said we got pizza papa and
uh we got reed richards in a very
different way but um interesting that
what that might say about reed richard's
potential in actual mcu
universe right and live the council of
reeds as well as like the way we have
him in the illuminati that that would
for comic fans make us more suspicious
like we would assume there's going to be
something whether or not that's the case
and how they use them also it might
eliminate certain continuity issues if
he's in that building we theorize he's
in from the 60s if he's trapped in time
and you show another read that's not our
read that would mess up things more so
he wrote that before he got the go ahead
this makes me think time displaced read
even more
yeah
uh thank you chrissy uh in the chat
thank you everybody that's sending in
some super chat uh we're gonna get to
those we're closing in on a hundred
dollar hulk out okay i like the way that
sounds 100 hellcat um i might just
incorporate that in my everyday life ah
but that's it whenever i spend or make a
hundred dollars
full back um
uh okay uh
some newly released concept art for thor
love and thunder revealed gore had much
more deadly intentions with the
kidnapped asgardian children uh the
artist george hull said this about that
concept art the early script had the
children's souls as necessary to enter
eden but in the end taika chose to
simplify the story and and the settings
for the better also yeah sucking the
souls out of uh children captured
children
might have been a little darker than
that foundation yeah stranger things
didn't even do that if things didn't
even do that maybe we shouldn't do it
yeah
yeah yeah so they went opposite and they
just imbued all the kids with the most
power possibilities because the
disparity of tones is already so like
the joke about like kids in a cage like
that joke wouldn't have landed if those
were soulless kids oh yeah you already
are balancing that type of there's a
dead child on the ground
i think it still collapses on the ground
for a minute
or did they wake up and then they're
like i want to play fortnite
[Laughter]
oh
[ __ ] i think we've crossed
our uh our threshold for hulking out um
real quick uh
you know what i'm going to hulk out
while promoting merch okay because i
feel strongly about it and oh oh no oh
no it's happening
right now you can go to our lurch
partners epic hero shop
and purchase
this latest obsession short lady justice
it's a limited edition shirt okay it
will be around forever she'll get one
now i'm not smart hulk this is dumb but
still verbose hulk ah so buy one now
from epic hero shop okay when you buy
one unlock potential to leave message
that will be read during inside marvel
episode with jessica and eric and mt
hulk doesn't speak and then smart health
just sounds like mark ruffalo so it's
like you've got to find that middle
ground right um also so you could get
we've got two latest obsession shirts
for sale right now at new
rockstarsmerch.com from our friends at
the epic hero shop that awesome uh
she-hulk lady justice shirt as well as
this cool um
house of the dragon shirt called ashen
ruin
uh not to be confused with fire and
blood ash and ruin um now if you buy
that shirt that unlocks the potential
leave a message that will be read on
talking dragons our game of thrones
after show also featuring jessica
clemons i'm in everything and brandon
barry uh jessica clements contractually
obligated to be on everything every
single time i volunteer voluntarily join
yes i could say no if i want it
i like it and we like avenue on it um
okay i teased this earlier it's been
sitting behind us entire episodes
we got um jessica's gonna lead us
through this disney released a new d23
poster uh
for the event next week that we're gonna
be covering here in new rockstars got
everybody amped because this bad boy is
new rockstars catnip okay
it's got it's got um easter eggs of
plenty and that's why i think do you
want to host this
than i do
um okay so yeah the disney uh d23 poster
just got released like zach said and it
has the most easter eggs and from
earlier i don't think a lot of channels
or anybody's really breaking down
exactly what is in this because this has
so many easter eggs of what we're gonna
see in the future of disney all disney
plus stuff even though the new rides
that are coming at disney world new uh
nature shows that are coming on disney
plus and we're gonna go through it and
discuss which everything is because we
broke it down and we figured it out so
do we want to take it from top to bottom
yes and just fyi we think we found them
all right we've been studying i think
and quick shout out to
uh brandon who's not here who was a big
help whitney was a big help and then
producer john as well as jessica have
been combing through this all day and
like some of these are controversial
we're going to need the chat
i think we should start with the most
controversial the second most
controversial because i think there's a
more controversial one we're gonna stop
at this start so we have tinker bell
here clearly that's tinker bell then we
have the star which we're getting mixed
notes from people whether it's captain
marvel evangeline from um princess and
the frog or it is just normally
tinkerbell star that she always kind of
like yeah then she dinks at the top of
the logo
or the pinocchio star there's so many
stars that it could be up in the air
peter pan star or peter pan star because
like she has a star but there's also the
second star to the right which is always
like extra bright right yes so there's a
lot of stars we maybe why don't we just
leave that to the chat yeah
if you want to try doing a poll datsun
or if you guys just want to keep telling
us which one it is then we'll see who it
all has who it could be okay sweet then
we have dumbo clearly the elephant
mm-hmm
yeah this is avatar yeah that's one of
the birds you can you see attack your
tail too and fly yeah
the navy bird the nominee okay
and we clearly have captain america's
shield and then we have the simpsons
donut yep we have over here we have evie
and then this is the new ride okay so
this is an important one that i think is
going to lead to a good discussion here
so that is a nova ship right as seen in
guardians of the galaxy vol 1.
uh and and we've seen images from uh the
guardians of the galaxy ride at epcot uh
that feature like a giant one of these
ships like outside but we also know
they've been talking about doing a nova
project for a long time is this kind of
i think guardian's three if anything's
gonna have nobody yeah like his team's
gun has wanted adam warlock and nova
from the jump so if he's doing his last
project i think would be the time to do
it yeah i think i think that not does it
it doesn't confirm but it's a pretty
good idea it's like two birds with one
stone with that easter egg exactly and
we were saying right like there's not a
ton of marvel stuff on here we talked
about sam shield that there's
one other one that we're going to get to
later so like it it is important for
some reason and they could have put a
lot of different spaceships there
putting that there is
the bowie it is just an overarching
blanket of like yeah it's a new ride
guardians and also maybe possibly will
give you no because it confirms anything
but i do think it when we look back
we'll well it could be like that was the
thing yeah i'm gonna also be bouncing
back you guys so follow my finger like
we're in school oh we have the epcot
ball clearly this is evil queen
maleficent
yeah and then
because is she getting another movie yes
i think she's getting a third john was
saying there's a maleficent 3 on the way
he's been demanding it his letter
writing campaign is finally paying for
them
bouncing back a little bit we got ganzo
we got winnie the pooh we got lilo and
stitch ladies this is a girl stitch
which i don't remember her name
oh because we're getting the live action
movie aren't we what was it john
angelo
we're getting the live-action movie soon
right i think it's been in talks so
maybe yeah scooby-doo style like where
there's cgi that's gonna be fun and
yeah oh that's true though i'm not ready
man just like like the
langoliers and then we got ratatouille
we got the yes yes sorry started
correctly why am i trying to fight you
guys i'm done answering i'm afraid come
back come back we have more star wars
over here
from new hampshire
and then what is this
that is a um it's a mascot for the
disney world park oh it goes way back in
the day it's uh not a super prominent
thing but it is it's a representative of
the parks okay perfect got it and
there's another star star wars ship this
is um
thank you guys then we have our lemur
okay that's one of our customers this is
one of the ones you don't know that we
need your help in the chat i agree with
john overarchingly that i think the uh
the monkey and the dolphin are both for
the disney pluses uh shows about nature
but if you in the chat if you know
of an in canon monkey no it's an
official yes we were saying it's
definitely not the aladdin monkey
right so it's definitely not that monkey
uh it has a blue face who knows i was
also saying it could be there's the
animal kingdom
in florida maybe they probably have
monkeys but it's in a place of
prominence so it must be a real cannon
monkey but anyway perfect and then we'll
bounce back over here because we have
another star there's a lot of stars the
boo fighter yeah and one is it and one
is what they called the starfighter the
new um benjarin ship that was uh
speaking of one
yeah let's not forget that this entire
thing is cinderella's castle all right
we have oswald the old old mickey my two
favorites we got the tron sphere and
woody's badge that's not what he's bad
because doesn't woody's badge have a
sheriff's star that is the sheriff
that's not what are you okay
so you guys is another controversial
thing in the chat i i may be wrong i may
be wrong but i think this is captain
wilson star because captain or captain
will captain america sam wilson star
because sam wilson's star is around a
blue circle on his arm and it's silver
and blue on his shirt and i think the
blue is his color no you think they
would have two representations yes
and this might and this is why i know i
could be wrong i don't think it's a good
idea to hand me down give him the same
logo oh i think he's going to get his
own
his own logo in the 2020 format well in
the comics right now he has a totally
different shield so i think it's going
to become his arm maybe his own eye
interesting
[Applause]
which i don't play but you guys do yeah
right this
yeah let's go to the pixar ball this is
leading us to aladdin's lamp down here
and then this is pete's dragon yeah
another peach dragon that movie is slept
on live action yeah yeah isn't it dragon
the one where they wanted to eat them
the child the child no that's like king
kong oh that's like the stoner one like
stoner or even puffs imagining
live action remake of that where they
reverse it and the boy is cgi the dragon
is real oh yeah
that's right that's right yeah and then
we have mulan we have elsa and then is
this beauty and the beast uh so we were
saying we think these two gargoyles are
from the haunted mansion that makes more
sense that makes more sense yes that
makes more sense come over here and this
is the dragon from the new uh or no from
enchantment
the live-action amy adams uh flight from
a couple years ago yeah okay perfect
that's vanellope sweets yeah
the wreck-it ralph franchise rapunzel
and then we have the octopus arm
yeah which we think is connected to this
is the old um uh yeah this is this is a
fun detail here at the bottom this is
the 20 000 leagues under the sea ride
that was an og disneyland disney world
ride that has been revamped to be a
fighting nemo ride and this is what the
submarines now look like this is what
the old submarines used to look like
perfect and we have princess and the
frog which again i think that star is
also princess on the frog um and i love
that movie and they're also getting
their new ride at disneyland oh the book
okay that's this is one of the ones that
we haven't been able to figure out um
there's some speculation in the office
that this is uh from hocus pocus
it doesn't look like the exact hocus
pocus book uh help us out in the chat if
you know what this little book is from
uh we don't know okay perfect and going
down i'm gonna go down here and then
i'll go back we have spider-man which
arguably you can go ahead
a bit yeah
one thing interesting is if you look
really close this logo is the andrew
garfield amazing spider-man um and
there's no black for tom holland exactly
no weird like there's no those web
shooter gauntlets from the so there's no
dignified spider-man so this is the
specifically the andrew garfield so does
that mean it's morbid time
we're wrecking the sponsor
it is interesting and this could just be
the artist's interpretation but this is
neither of the spider-man you will see
in the parks this is also a sony
property right they could have put all
kinds of other marvel characters here
that are wholly owned by marvel they
chose to do this shared character
interesting is it the comic accurate
which i mean andrew garfield's the
closest comic accurate both in suit in
my opinion
personality but i do think that is uh
either andrew garfield or comic tape
it's just that this that long legs there
is like specifically the andrew garfield
but yeah they're long spider
we have turning red on both sides the
the two different statues and then we
have the s what is this one it is the
adventurer society which is like
a canon kind of like in park thing
they're trying to make like a shared
universe between like the jungle crews
and some other
rides within the park uh that are also
going to be maybe turned into theatrical
things so that's their life the jungle
cruise ship is here next to it like
right yes that is the jungle cruise
steamship there yeah and then what's
this one that's the shang chi logo that
is the shanxi logo
you guys are better so this is these are
important here so we got the shanxi logo
and then over here we got the black
panther logo again
those are
two marvel logos there's a lot of other
logos they could have picked right well
it's because this is coming out i think
we're going to hear at d23 chongqing
attached to a bunch of properties
because we keep hearing like all sorts
of great semul quotes where he's like
i'm gonna be busy we know that in what
if isn't he supposed to be a big problem
uh and also
yeah he's gonna be attached to literally
everything yeah uh we have our um
indiana jones
indiana jones we already did the aladdin
we have the uh submarine that's finding
nemo because it's being redone we have
black panther monsters are they doing
another monster thing i think so we
don't know we're speculating i think
there's a
disney plus series planned okay perfect
and then we got another star wars that's
andor yeah
and again that's why it's interesting so
we know wakanda forever is coming out
andor is coming out in the next couple
weeks right so there must be some
something is coming out in the shop you
think the bottoms are just like the prep
yeah like these are because again this
whole thing is not for disney in general
but for d23 this year and you know
indiana jones is coming out too right
yeah yeah yeah yeah we're going to get
an extended trailer like the one we saw
at celebration right i think we'll get
more footage here yeah i think this will
literally be the schedule yeah this
is december it's 10 a.m
11 a.m
12 is here
oh yeah
represents a dot on the clock
you guys this is the break room
breakdown it is not eric boss's
breakdown we would put it to an actual
physical clock so we have luca right
here we have moana yep and then uh this
is jungle cruise and then we have the
little mermaid tail
and
there we go of course the steamboat
willy
real quick in the chat did anybody have
any good theories about the monkey
or the book they're saying in the chat
they're like it has to be uh hocus pocus
which i want to agree with but there is
no i and there's three other symbols on
it there's so many other people so could
it be
well now now we were saying it's not it
doesn't seem to be the same book from
the original film the original but of
course they're making a sequel maybe
there's a new book it's an upgraded book
it doesn't look like the book of shanty
no and and tom was saying it's not the
name of my name
i'm pretty sure don't quote me but it
might not be the
car there's a bunch of witch movies
coming though you think it can be
another witch book like it can't be
another one from
this is tantalizing because like you
know some of these are like recent
properties like turning red some of
these might be like um popular things or
do we got something in the chat so well
i i don't think so but i would love it
if it was the page master oh oh if they
bring back if they bring it i will cry
and throw up my colleagues
what if he becomes the uh the bad guy
the the uh jekyll and hyde yeah
i'd cry
and maybe we'll have to revisit this
next week after both disney plus day and
d23 right because like uh again we know
we're getting an ahsoka series we know
we're getting an indoor series some of
these things are obvious and some of
these things are slightly less obvious
oh you know someone in the chat just
said um agatha um
what if this is what if this is the well
the darker
the thing is it has a crown
and these symbols kind of look like
capsules yeah
oh so yeah like was there a book in
brave or something like that i don't
know no there was the bears and i love
brave i watch it all the time also feel
like they they that could be an
announcement that we're about to get and
that could be like i mean
we're getting two people saying national
treasure and they are making another
national treasure good call good call in
the chat percy jackson it could be percy
jackson
i will throw this through the ceiling if
it is percy jackson i wanted to be in it
they won't let me audition i'm too old
uh
any good monkey theories in the video
yeah who is this lemur and what does he
do yes
blue face little guy uh friends reboot
marcel um we'll never know um okay thank
you that was great jessica uh i think we
did it
yeah
i think we did it if anybody can do a
better live breakdown of a poster filled
with easter eggs goddammit subscribe to
their channel we got you guys pretty
sure john coming in with a message no
he's just focusing the camera okay real
quick let's run through a couple uh
super chats um gregory ditrich any idea
why the break room can't be downloaded
anymore oh i actually
have no idea there might be a little
change in the youtube back end we have
not changed anything gregory but maybe
john's
oh do we got producer john here with a
report i'm sorry i'm sorry youtube isn't
processing our videos correctly oh okay
that's that's on youtube gregory but
we'll get it fixed uh because we want
you to be able to download the
the uh show uh chrissy mcu jake lockley
versus matt murdock who would win and
what would the finisher move be matt
murdock
really easy okay
my thing about okay this is my theory
matt uh win against literally everybody
uh the fact that he went over what's his
name in the third in the third season
yeah the fact that he destroyed bullseye
kingpin like no there is no way that
jake lockley with just a gun and konshu
who can
heal him if he wants to uh will actually
pull through against madrid also i mean
we've we've always paralleled daredevil
and batman but there's always the talk
of like that and can beat anybody with
enough time i feel like daredevil does
it real time like i feel like
daredevil's always ready and moon knight
almost lost a fight to a guy and a horse
i'm not trying to be that person i'm not
going to be liver then that's true
he just just started with a french
accent also i think uh i would bet more
on uh not stephen um not stephen who's
the other one um
and mark mark i bought more money
than i would but
we've seen daredevil dodge guns in that
thing before and it seems like jake
leads guns and mark leads finesse
whereas stephen is is you know the the
navigable fighter so easy also i think i
think uh matt could take way more damage
well and and
the reason he almost lost the fight to
the horse was because it was switching
between personas and i feel like i
wouldn't trust daredevil to not be able
to manipulate that yeah like daredevil
could find a way to like play against
his 100 points you could fight but i
would love that he's way better with the
billy clubs
and again um we're assuming chrissy met
in a physical fight and not in a
courtroom battle uh because that's not
even a contest right jake likely does
not have a law degree he is uh not
licensed by any bar is there really a
rafiki spin-off or is that jokes and
dreams
cause i mean about it maybe it's
unannounced i will say one thing that i
think we're getting on disney uh plus
day that is not on there unless you guys
can spot something they are making a
santa claus series that will be out this
winter um i don't see any santa claus
reference
we're getting a lot of planet of the
apes and i did not even know planet of
the apes was being redone oh well that's
a fox property so it is no it isn't it
is a disney park but would it why would
you choose that one
i just put a record that's not it cause
it has a tail that is a monkey it could
be a bonobo
monkeys
when you pick a monkey not a warthog not
a lion not a monkey king uh anyways okay
there were
is the lemur monkey a madagascar movie
that was nickelodeon wasn't it well
madagascar might have been a fox thing
that is now owned by disney i'm actually
not exactly sure who made them
i watched madagascar and nickelodeon
like the the tv show so i think it's not
disney but i don't know
madagascar saga you know what we will
not rest until we find out what the hell
that money is our monday news that's
right
that's right we will keep a monkey watch
going every day on the break room until
we solve this mystery thank you for
everybody uh submitting in the chat your
ideas um this was a lot of fun uh disney
keep giving us cool posters and we'll
keep breaking them down um real quick uh
we want to thank the folks that um
helped bring this episode to you which
today is aspiration hey what if there
was a credit card that can tackle your
negative impact on our climate just by
using it once a day that's the
aspiration zero credit card aspiration
zero is the first credit card that
fights climate change by planting trees
with every swipe uh with an aspiration
zero credit card you plant two trees
with every purchase you make which soaks
up about the same amount of carbon
dioxide from the air as the average
person puts out every day good to know
uh and along with the reward of knowing
that you've turned your purchase into a
way to do your part to save the planet
you get unlimited one percent cash back
on all your monthly purchases when you
hit carbon zero for the month hell yeah
you know what's better than zero percent
cash back
one percent cash oh yeah uh aspiration
aspiration has already planted 75
million trees that's a lot of trees make
your dollars make a difference apply for
the aspiration zero credit card today
and earn a three hundred dollar welcome
bonus after spending three thousand
dollars in your first 90 days and right
now at aspiration.com
break room uh head there to go carbon
neutral effortlessly and earn a 300
bonus again that's aspiration.com break
room thank you aspiration uh the
aspiration zero mastercard is issued by
beneficial state bank pursuant to
licensed by mastercard international
incorporated good credit required terms
and conditions apply
i love it on the radio when they do that
super fast i've always wanted to get
that job yes the guy the speed reader
the fine print guy yeah
but again thank you aspiration for uh
helping bring the break room to you
today now
um as we said earlier she-hulk episode
three comes out tonight
um i'm excited there's a lot of stuff
that's been hinted at in trailers that
we've yet to see portrayed on screen uh
there's been all these rumors of a
certain uh female pop star that might be
showing up in this episode um it's
anybody's game is what's gonna happen
but
we've been doing here on the break room
our fantasy prediction league for
she-hulk all season long where we've
been picking uh each of us has been
predicting what's gonna happen then
points are rewarded the following day uh
we have a running tally of points for
the whole season at the end of the
season whoever has the most points and
that includes the audience is going to
get
i don't think the audience gets there i
don't know including oh there's our
running tally so far oh we got we got
tom already has 10 i've got 10.
jessica's 15. coy is 11.
um and then brandon and tommy and eric
wussu also have uh their picks uh and
then that that garbage can in the middle
that's you the audience okay
uh that's you trash bags at home um and
again whoever has the most points by the
other season gets a fancy meal
for free of their choosing and if the
audience wins we literally have to buy a
fancy meal for the only one only one of
them
will share that's right everybody gets a
third of a bite um but uh so for today
uh we have three different things that
we're predicting jessica do you want to
lead us on that um yeah okay so
it's week three for our shield fantasy
predictions and it's still anyone's game
this week our three predictions are oh
let's just go through them one by one
okay so will emil blonsky get paroled
yes or no in this episode in this
episode in episode three i think so i
think so if you don't want to show her
as a bad lawyer and like earlier
immediately
and the conflict would be interesting
because like if he wins that's more
conflicting narratively 100 percent yes
and i think for sure he will because
they they're gonna need to set him up
for thunderbolts which we're already
expecting him to be in so he's
definitely getting he's definitely
getting pulled and it might be on a type
of suicide squad contract the only way i
can see him not getting paroled is so
they need thunderbolts like right like a
suicide squad situation that's true but
i i also still think it's more important
to show jennifer walters skill yeah show
that she's a good lawyer or if it takes
longer than this episode maybe it's like
the beginning of the fourth episode
instead but i i think we've held on to
him two episodes is enough you're gonna
say yes as well yeah i'm gonna say yes
i'm gonna say yes as well but i think he
gets paroled this episode but by the end
of the season he's back in jail
um okay oh the second one who will jen
go on a date with who will jen go on a
date with
um
who have we seen so far
we even met a lot of eligible bachelors
per se well you said earlier which i
really liked is that the guy running the
comic book shop at the uh
glk h the older gentleman with the comic
books
are like oh my god
yeah so i like that i like that one
actually um
i don't i'm trying to think of all the
guys that are in the episode there's
dennis there's pug pug i feel like he's
a pretty good candidate
yeah um
a meal she could be one of the seven
partners oh interesting
i was thinking that she would i mean i
don't know if he's going to be in this
but of course daredevil's coming up oh i
wanna that would be a good one and maybe
it'd be funny if they hooked up and he
was just matt murdock and she didn't
know he was daredevil
something like classic scenario she goes
on a date with matt murdock and then has
a fight with daredevil and doesn't
realize they're the same person i'm
gonna say she goes
is this is this is this a cheat this is
what tommy said last last episode and i
kind of want to do this can i say that
she'll go on a date with nikki
oh
oh like they're just a romantic date or
they're just out having drinks see are
we trying to say romantic or we're just
trying to say they're hanging out
minute date as well dave is romantic i
think we're going to imply romero then
i'll i'll say
that i'll say
i'll say pug i'll say pogba oh i like
that i'm going to go with the character
i want to see on screen so badly that
even if it's statistically improbable i
will hedge my bet stilt man i don't want
to steal man for 14 years you bring me
stilt man he's the only one
right
now i want him to watch
does she hold it i
i think we deserve stilt man and they
they said c and d list characters were
coming you give me a rocket racer you
give me the big wheel you give me
stillness
this might be quasi cheating or too safe
a bet i'm going to say the the scene
from the trailer where she carries the
handsome shaved head gentlemen
i'm seeing that guy that makes sense now
is that is that is that shitty of me
probably what if they don't whatever
or they just go jump straight to the bed
he just he just knocks on the door and
then there he has pizza delivery
oh hell yeah
i would i would like to be wrong about
that and get that scene here to fix your
plumbing
extra sausage okay how many how many
news reports will we see on the blonsky
case or we were saying this is like
reporters reporting like on the steps
and we're excluding the entire crew like
a van does not count yeah
um oh and it's over under so you get to
say over which is 5.5 and over or uh 5.5
is under or yeah yeah do you pick do you
think it's gonna be more than 5.5 or
less than 5.5 i think it's going to be
less i'm saying less too
i'm gonna go over i'm gonna go over yeah
i feel like a montage will catch us this
show's moving at a good pace yeah and i
feel like we're gonna need to show the
scope of her reach and we already have
her as the only lawyer like a superhero
lawyer so we need to see what she's
reaching so i think they might montages
or they would have everybody on the
steps at the same time like general oh
that's also what's going on
that's kind of coming right off the
courtroom
even though i'm saying under i think it
i like where you guys heads are at
because it's also a great way of yeah
again showing that like this is an
important case in the world of the mcu
right like it's a way cheaper way than
having 200 extras or something like that
i immediately was thinking who's going
to be at the prison getting interviews
that's who i immediately thought but i
didn't think about the episode in the
episode i'm going to go over absolutely
there's going to be people on the news
covering okay and then there's going to
be people physically there bring it over
one under okay okay okay uh and and in
the chat you can pick who you want to
follow this week that's how the audience
accrues points you select one of our uh
one of our picks and that becomes your
de facto picks as well and you get the
number of points that the person you
pick gets a lot of
sorry a lot of people in the chat for
date said wong and i i know
that's a good one i want to give some
love to kyle for saying pace pot pete
because i love the trapster that
character is amazing
he literally like his power is like glue
he's like he's like a crappy spider-man
where his webbing is his only main thing
but he's like a bad henchman and he
trashed people in paste
pop
taste oh he's the best i was one of the
car in the chat
i hate him
my nemesis film juice said uh the monkey
is for the spanking
you know what you didn't need to every
time i think you know what maybe film
just isn't that bad of a person you know
maybe film juice like we got off on the
wrong foot but i'm sure we get along
fine you do something like this
okay you reaffirm every bad thought i've
ever had about you i'm practically
hulking out right now on your film juice
and we haven't even had a multiple of a
hundred dollars shame on you you're the
ultimate trash bag other trash bags get
put into you that's how much of a trash
bag you are
okay sorry hefty bag
um okay but yeah as always in the chat
uh uh select whose votes you'd like to
uh
co-opt
and those will be the the audience vote
i don't know have we been running any
chats is birthday boy um we have do we
go over the polls oh no we haven't gone
over polls please
have you been watching the currencies of
harley quinn 77 percent of you say no i
don't like the way we set up that poll
oh my gosh oh it's amazing you guys need
to watch it actually 22 saying yes is a
decent number yeah right yeah 77 is a
lot uh would you like to see emma watts
as the new chief of dc films 61 percent
of you signing out okay
uh battle angel fans out there maybe
absolutely they were saying in the chat
they're going off sound off in the chat
uh is the post credit scene better or
worse than pizza papa is this post
credit scene better or worse than pizza
papa uh they said yes sick
better or worse and the answers are yes
or no
yes it's better or
well they're saying yes it's both better
or worse i love that we're like
okay let me this is
and then um what could the star on the
poster mean at the top that we were
speculating wrong
pretty strong saying captain marvel
interesting followed by tinker bell
other and then pinocchio
uh bringing up the rear we are precious
yes we're getting i just we're getting
both a live-action tom hanks pinocchio
joint but i think that is a disney
official we're also getting a probably
creepy gamo del
[Laughter]
i'm saying this with a grain of salt
like take it with a grain of salt the
most unproblematic old oldest disney
movie i mean if you're happy if you're
half donkey it is still kind of
problematic see as as a a woman that
identified as a girl uh my entire life i
was immediately like oh thank god i'm
never gonna be taken here when i was a
child watching i was like oh thank god i
can smoke cigars and be crazy and not be
turned into a donkey uh who
whose pics are you guys betting on 47
said me and it's probably because if we
bring up those scores again i'm leading
baby you know what it's not that's not
wrong if you audience to to ride the
jessica train uh throughout the season
she's been doing great and and nobody's
been paying closer attention to she-hulk
as she's been breaking down all the
episodes again look for that tomorrow or
friday no tomorrow tomorrow that'll be
on the channel her breakdown uh that'll
be awesome we're going to be excited to
watch that episode tonight and all the
episodes of she-hulk
um okay i think this is a good place to
wrap up again plugs for the week and for
next week um next week we're covering
d23 we're covering disney plus day we'll
be reacting live next a week from this
saturday we'll be having a special
saturday morning-ish show depending on
what time zone you're in we'll be
reacting live to uh d23 we're gonna have
a couple correspondents down in anaheim
on the floor some vote some faces you
might recognize from the break room and
other new rock stars properties uh are
gonna be doing some phone-ins making
some cool content and then we'll have
some some folks here in the studio
reacting to that as well uh so you know
what if if this wet your whistle
that whistle's gonna get soaked next
week you know what i mean oh my god
what is your quote what is your quote of
the break room um i'll tell you what i'm
always horny or whatever yeah yeah my
secret is i'm always horny oh god no one
listens to soap whistle
hashtag soaked whistles
ah thank you jessica and tom so much for
joining us here thank you everybody in
the chat we appreciate you uh like and
subscribe
um to this channel in general if you
like the break room uh why not subscribe
to new rock stars and hey go to
newrockstarsmerch.com get one of those
cool ladies obsession limited edition
shirts either the one for she-hulk or
the one for house of the dragon between
those two properties i bet you're vibing
on at least one of them if not both grab
yourself a shirt look cool around town
uh thank you we'll be back tomorrow
same time same place bye